yeah we asked the audience about their
biggest fears and let's let's just delve
amongst just for having before you say
anything Ruffalo will take you down okay
okay so hands up if you've got if you've
got a fear we asked me booked a nice
lady here I what are you afraid of
cotton wall oh she's okay with bugs are
you one of those people who can't get
the pills out of the bottle it's just in
bags and when someone takes the pile out
and it starts making that noise oh oh
yeah oh they like that noise who was
over here and I say to here what are you
afraid of
um bread sweat breads wet bread sweat
what's breaks we're all right I'll set
the scene
as an action when we've made toast then
you put it on the side and lift it up
and it's all wet and the crumbs and just
you're afraid of that I have a fear of
loose change it's the sound of change in
people's pockets or anything like that
so if I'm given change in my hand before
a receipt I tend to just throw up in the
air
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
who else we use which was I'm actually
afraid of sperm in places it's not
supposed to be what your forensic
scientists yes I feel like it's
everywhere and it freaks me out I think
you should have your couch checked out
[Applause]
at any one what I've got I've gone one
of those little CSI things
men are now singing oh okay so what's
your name then Dean okay come out here
Dean put your hat down okay Stan okay
let's bring the lights down
[Applause]
[Music]
stead of focus it's not easy what are
you afraid of well I was gonna go with
flying but I think I'll go with girls
over 12